76 percent of 18 to 24 year old American
men would be ineligible to serve in the
armed forces because of health or
criminal record problems obesity and
other sort of Health complications I
quote tweeted it saying America's if
there's a land Invasion I got a bunch of
responses in the replies explaining why
America would be really hard to invade
by land and I was like that's not the
lesson to take away from this issue the
lessons take away from this issue is
that you have a very unready populace ah
yeah but there's lots of water there's
mountains in the middle of the country
yeah sure like that's correct but
relying on structure as opposed to
relying on capability seems like a
weakness